L nasx you remember L NSX he is uh best
known for filming a music video where he
uh is being uh violated by the Devil
Himself but he's kind of enjoying it uh
Lil nasx has been teasing that he's had
a change of heart and he's going to
become a
Christian don't bug your girl is B
are me returning to God after the
industry tried to make me
satanic now he's there and it looks kind
of fake doesn't it this reminds me the
second I saw this video this reminded me
of Snoop Dogg who did kind of fool me he
posted on the internet he said I'm
giving up smoke please respect my
privacy in this time
Snoop and he said Snoop Dogg he smokes
pot all day long what are you talking
about and then I'm giving up smoke with
it just became a a marketing campaign
for a a stove like a smokeless grill
that he he was trying to sell and so the
minute I saw that I said okay Lil nasx
here this guy is I don't buy it it can
happen I think it happened with Kanye I
think Kanye actually had a sincere
moment of repentance when he made that
album Jesus is King and he banned people
who were working on the album from
fornicating and all and then you know
unfortunately he had some public
backsliding as has happened to a lot of
people um but I didn't think that's what
was going on with little NSX I thought
it was kind of fake you know we we
God can do anything and turn any heart
but I I didn't really see it here and so
anyway now he's released this album and
it is exactly as Blasphemous as you
might imagine we'll get to that in one
second right now go to genucell.com
nsyt let's make a resolution that you
are sure to stick with with genus cell
skincare you can turn back the clock and
look five 10 even 15 years younger right
now genus cell skincare is celebrating
2024 with its New Year's Sales Event you
will save over
77% off all your genus cell musthaves in
their most popular package say goodbye
to those Fine Lines forehead wrinkles
sagging jawline dark marks skin redness
and under eye bags Janus cell works for
women and men is safe for all skin types
and is perfect for skin of any age plus
with its immediate effects Jus cell
promises results that will make you
smile guaranteed or 100% of your money
back I love this company and the founder
of this company Copic Christian who left
Egypt for the American dream the product
uses the very best ingredients a lot of
people ask how can genus cell afford to
Discount their first order so much you
know is it just really marked up or
something no it's not they're taking a
hit on that first order because they are
so confident that you are going to keep
using their product for years and years
to come and I'm confident of that too
enjoy maximum skin hydration for a more
youthful appearance Jus cell.com nsyt
letter y letter T enter code nsyt at
check out for extra savings every order
automatically upgraded to free shipping
don't wait jus.com
nsyt code nsyt T okay little NSX is
making a big PR stunt and I guess we're
all falling for it he says he's going to
become a Christian take it
[Applause]
[Music]
away yeah bust down chain now was 30 bin
bust down wrist that's my bust down 30
in walk up in the club popping like it
was double let him slide yeah wasn't Qui
yeah tell him come outside
[Music]
baby so you've got this dueling battle
between Heaven and Hell he's in both
places and he's playing a basketball
game and the angel Beats the
devil and then he goes into a little
cheerleader
thing is with the I know which way that
we going hm this
way then he He makes himself into Christ
but he does it upside down which is a
satanic symbol of a a cross upside down
is not satanic but a crucifix upside
down is a satanic
symbol and they're on the
flood before anyone is in Christ he New
Creation the old has passed away behold
the new has come 2 Corinthians
5:17 yeah true okay that's not the whole
video my producers spared me having to
watch the whole thing two
takeaways which are two things that
we've been talking about actually all
show that's the first time I'm seeing
that music video One
is weird sex stuff is not just frivolous
and silly it it's really bad I'm not
saying it's the worst kind of sin but
it's really bad and it leads one to much
worse sins when we read about ancient
Pagan Cults or when we read about the
Israelites in the desert turning away
from God and worshiping
uh golden
calf I don't know what kind of image
people usually form in their minds I but
I think it's a kind of benign image and
it's that's not that when ancient Pagan
Cults would engage in their rituals when
the Israelites in the desert started
worshiping a golden calf they weren't
just sort of standing there and kneeling
down and bowing they were doing lots of
weird sex stuff and and this music video
opens up little nasx is in heaven and he
looks like an angel but he's got this
this sex collar around his neck which is
which is significant because what he's
saying is I'm I'm basically a slave to
sex right that's the collar that is
around my neck and then you quickly
realize that this this angel of Light is
a demon and and this vision of Heaven is
really a rather hellish Vision that's
the first thing it's not just funny
games if it feels good do
it if it feels good and you have been
well formed and well educated and
brought up in your desire have been
cultivated in a healthy way then feeling
good can be a good thing and that can
lead you toward more good things and a
flourishing life but if you've grown up
in a corrupted way if you have been
traumatized if you've been Mal educated
if if very nasty desires have been
cultivated in you and vices have been
cultivated and habits have been left
neglected then if it feels good is
usually a signal that you should not do
that thing because you you because we're
creatures of habit and so if you've
cultivated very bad habits then then the
things that feel good are going to be
really bad for you and if you've
cultivated good habits the things that
feel good are going to be good for you
this is what Aristotle talks about the
nicoman ethics there are four kinds of
people in this world the ones who do bad
things and love doing bad things the
ones who want to do good things but they
do bad things they're incontinent the
ones who want to do bad things but they
basically manage to avoid doing bad
things but it's still very hard for them
those are the people who are who are
continent and then there are The
Virtuous people who who who want to do
good things and actually succeed at
doing good things and we should strive
for the the latter but in this day and
age especially with the society we live
in it's virtually impossible that's the
first thing that strikes me about that
video the second thing that strikes me
about that music video is
that all this bad
stuff is just an attack on good stuff
all false religion is just a parody of
of the True
Religion it's it's a perversion or an
inversion or outright denial of the True
Religion what is this satanic worship
service it's called the black mass and
it's just an inversion of it's a mockery
of the true mass of the Catholic mass
this music video which is which is
Blasphemous and
sacriligious just like his last one
where he's getting strued by the devil
what is it is it is it something of his
own creation is this the new little nasx
religion no it's just a mockery of True
Religion
Christianity so many ideologies are just
mockeries of True Religion communism is
a mockery of the true religion that that
changes the nature of freedom and
slavery and and oppression and and
Redemption and it perverts them into a
very materialist kind of way liberalism
is a mockery of Christianity that
substitutes man for God but it it has
the same language it has the same
trappings it has the same behavior the
thing that unites all of those false
ideologies is they're just parodies of
the real thing that's a good clip huh
now oh
up ring the bell subscribe to the
Michael NS YouTube channel and we will
see you next time